in the middle of the game you'll see him  from time to time especially if you come  to the arena  pull a guy over and just kind of talk to  him for a little bit doesn't wait till  after the game or halftime  wants to teach right on the spot love  that  pork who tweaked a right ankle earlier  returning here in the second half  chris paul with 18 of his 28 second half  [Applause]  [Applause]  seriously  watch this first of all i can't believe  you missed it  but then jojo clean rebound one motion  look at  that that would have been a sports  center  forever look at that  look at that that's online mark  [Applause]  the presence of mine right look at that  on target oh can you imagine that  you know that's that's one of those  shots that at the end of practice or the  end of shoot around you know what i mean  right guys goof around they will often  put wagers out there and then b nearly  tied